in this week's discussion of video we're
going to show you some interesting
examples of other people's work now
remember that the basics of still
photography that you've just learned all
these previous weeks apply to making
successful videos for starters we are
incredibly lucky to be able to show you
some remarkable videos from a project
called beautiful chemistry here's the
website with full credit
now I encourage you to see them all I am
quite sure they will inspire you to come
up with your own amazing videos if your
work requires video capturing
macro-level phenomena scientist young
liang a collaborator of mine is the
creator and director of the project we
asked him to tell us a little about his
techniques for three of the videos
welcome liang to our class thank you
fleece is wonderful being part of this
course I'll be happy to talk about how
we capture three particular phenomena in
this segment we are sewing metal
displacement reactions the job [ __ ]
marrow in two different solutions and
recorded the emergence of beautiful
structures of other metals such as sewer
and LED oh the reactions were shot in
real time and we sped them up during
editing in Final Cut Pro X for example
once out of silver displacement was sped
up 60 times which means one second of
our video is one minute in real time for
life setup we use two large LED panels
to light a cubic glass container in
which the reactions occurred typically a
black clothes or white plastic board was
placed about one foot behind a container
as black a white background
we shot reactions in the front who is a
Panasonic gh4 camera and a 100
millimeter macro lens elder reactions
were shot in a normal lab with
fluorescent lights because the LED
panels were so much brighter than the
fluorescent lights they typically live
damar in this segment we are seeing a
few crystallization processes including
crystallization of copper sulfate sodium
cell sulfate and two more
we chose crystallization processes that
are fast enough so that we could suit in
real time and speed them up in editing
they did not say like crystallization
process that could take hours or days to
form large crystals for those Templars
photography has to be used a lighting
and exposure have to be carefully
controlled to avoid flicker in a final
video finally in this segment we are
showing a few bubbling reactions such as
zinc metal reacts with hydrochloric acid
to form hydrogen bubbles these reactions
were fast and usually we did not speed
them up in editing our let's set up work
well for bubbles the wet highlights on
the right and left side of the bubbles
are a reflection of the two LED panels
this highlights gave bubbles are very
interesting look
you